Lesson number four.
Authority. This lesson basically is sort of a response.
It's invoking a response from your students of the, if the Bible is all that we've
said the Bible is so far, then now what?
Because the Bible clearly has something to say that's really, really important
and has some authority over our lives.
So now what? Okay, so let's start with the storyteller.
The storyteller could be this week, and I would suggest it to be this week, a
student. I would ask your students who has
been greatly impacted over the last couple of weeks.
I would ask your students like hey who has really just like their mind completely
blown and needs to like just get it off their chest about what this means because
now they're going to have a changed life moving in the direction that God desires
and maybe that's in connect in connection with a retreat or a specific moment in
their life but if you've got a student like that then I would highly encourage
you to utilize that because what happens in these kinds of moments is that it's
really easy for an adult to say, this book is important.
You should follow it.
Well, they're still learning this book as many of us are as well and it's hard for
them to really grasp like, okay, well, what parts do I follow and how do I follow
and what's literal and what's not?
There's just so many other things here that they often look at us adults as like,
yeah, but you've got it figured out and you can do it and I don't need that right
now, I'm young and I can do what I want and when I'm your age maybe I'll do that and
I get that it's important and I'll get there.
It's more powerful if one of their peers stands up and declares
based on the evidence, based on what we've studied, based on the conviction of the
Holy Spirit, I believe this book to be authoritative and I'm going to respond in
that way and make sure my life is headed down the path that God wants it to go.
That's a powerful, powerful statement and a powerful storyteller if they can sort of
recall like how that happened. And you might have other students that maybe that is
happening to them and they just either don't realize it or aren't willing to speak
up about it. That might conjure up some other feelings from some other students and
give you a little bit of a gauge where you're at.
If you don't have a student, then I would suggest that that's in that space, that
maybe you have a graduate, someone that has gone through your program
and is now in college, and now that things are kind of rolling
along and they've been into college for a little bit of time, maybe they're starting
to experience some things. Maybe they're starting to see the importance of what's in
here, especially some of the contradictions they may be hearing on the college
campus. Have them come in and talk about the Bible's authority and
fill that storyteller role. Okay, so we say it all the time and we hear it all
the time, right? The Bible is the Word of God.
And what we're saying is that the Bible is inspired.
The Bible is infallible. The Bible is the Word of God.
It's everything in it is absolutely true.
Therefore, it must be authoritative, right?
But what students will often struggle with and what you'll hear in terms of
objections is this, that the Bible was written by
men.
Wait a minute, how can the Bible be authoritative?
And yeah, okay, sure, it can be historical and okay, yeah, I can fulfill prophecy
and okay, it can be completely accurate in some kind of strange way, but how can it
be so authoritative that we call it the word of God, that we call it the very
commands of God handed down from him to us so that we can live the
way he has designed us to live, if it was written by men.
How do we know that what Matthew
recorded when he recorded the words of Jesus, that he actually recorded the words of
Jesus? I mean, I probably wouldn't get it right.
I was listening to our sermon just on Sunday and I tried to write down exactly what
the pastor said because I really liked what he said in one particular sentence and
And I couldn't remember exactly what he said in that moment.
How could we expect Matthew to write down everything that Jesus said perfectly?
These are the kinds of objections that you will get from your students.
And it's not a terribly difficult objection to deal with, but just to kind of paint
the picture for you the way I've done it with students in the past is that think of
it this way. And I'm not making an exact equation, but it helps paint a better
picture is you have Jesus and you have the Bible.
Now clearly, we don't treat the Bible the same way we treat Jesus.
However, we very easily say that Jesus is 100% man
and he's also 100% God.
But wait a minute, if I can comfortably say that, why can't I comfortably say that
the Bible was written by men, inspired by God to be completely accurate?
See, if God can make this sort of thing happen, God can make this sort of thing
happen. It's pretty simple. The second objection that you'll often hear students
make is that the Bible may be accurate and historical and all those things, but the
Bible is simply a book about God.
That it's man's recordings of who God is or who they thought
him to be.
Now, that's not accurate either because if the Bible is authoritative then sure
what we think about God but it was completely accurate about who
God actually is because otherwise we don't know then who God really is
but we do know who God really is because he came in Jesus so we actually do have
that picture
so this is so your students start to see that although it seems very easy to say
other things about the Bible, which really just allows us to excuse ourselves on
various types of sin. That what the Bible teaches is 100%
authoritative. So as you're in your small groups, as you're thinking through all
these things, think through the implications of what all of this means.
These last four weeks, what all of this is coming, what conclusions are your
students now coming to? And I want you to remember three specific things that your
students can understand and know truth through all of this, is that one, they should
have a greater appreciation for this.
So if nothing else, they should have a greater appreciation for the Bible, what it
says, what it teaches, how it came together, all of those pieces that hopefully will
compel them to read a little bit more.
Secondly, that they'll be more inclined to read this.
How many Christians have read the Bible cover to cover multiple times
it's the greatest book but greatest biggest selling best-selling book in the
history of the world probably the least read book in the history of the world and I
think they're more likely to follow the more they appreciate the more they'll read
the better they'll follow that is the aim of um
of this week now this has to sort of cross into
we're gonna start talking in next few weeks here about what this means in
conversation when your students are in college when your students are talking with
friends you might be sitting reading this and someone makes a comment how do they
then defend and talk intelligently about this biblical text
And I think over the last four weeks, we've been able to provide
the tools that our students need to be able to talk intelligently about what this
book is all about.